[Music]
after having been you know we've
traveled for the as a family for the
past few thanksgivings
and so this was sort of the first uh
like
well we've done we did like the
friendsgiving thing years ago but
right this was kind of a new a new group
of people
and um the people who invited us were
very close to
but then they kind of invited a lot of
people that they know that they're close
to so there was people that
i had seen like once and there was
people i'd never seen
you know like 25 people at this
friendsgiving which is big in l.a yeah
because you've got all these people who
don't go back home and nobody is with
their
extended family and so you don't want to
find yourself alone in the sheets
and you got a lot of you got a lot of
single people you got a lot of
uh young couples without children
and so i think between basically just
you know me and my kids and then one of
their family and their kids were the
only like
families with kids and everybody else
was you know
younger that's not more vibrant i saw a
picture of the group
sharp looking group big group i'd say
there was 24 people 20 or 25
25 people yeah yeah you dressed up a
little bit for it
i did i thought that you did it looked
like you were wearing a sweater i had a
sweater on yeah i had my thanksgiving
sweater on oh yeah yeah it's made out of
turkey feathers
if you've been close enough you could
have seen that
i'll have to zoom in out of my cranberry
pants but you couldn't see that baby
because because of the angle it the
pants were made out of
like the the skins of cranberries the
skin that hangs off a turkey's neck
yeah right they're just bright red
wrinkly looks like leather unless you
get close turkey nut sack
scrotum pants but the scardam does hang
from the chin of attacking.com
so i was i was very excited
uh because you know me i love to eat
and i was very excited because uh the
friend
of the person who's kind of throwing
this was like they're gonna take care of
the food
um and a few people did make
make things to bring like my wife made
a sweet potato casserole southern style
with some pecans on top brown sugar you
know
uh just just a traditional thanksgiving
side very good
and here's what i'll say i call that a
pre-dessert not a side number
i enjoyed the meal quite a bit
you had your you had your staples and
your turkey
your gravy um your cranberry
sauce chutney whatever
and then like the sides that people had
brought uh
but i did notice something you know
first of all there was obviously a vegan
option
for basically everything and this is los
angeles so you got like a vegan option
for the church but it wasn't like a tofu
turkey they had like seitan
which i call satan i just go straight
for that
it's very big of you to invite satan to
your thanksgiving celebration
satan's steak we have cut him up and
served him on thanksgiving
be thankful for his death um
but the thing that i kind of noticed is
that
the only thing on my plate
that had the quantities of butter and
sugar and flour
that i feel like constitutes
thanksgiving yeah was what my wife
brought and i got to say
i know that that's just a southern boy
coming to los angeles
i i specifically remember one of the
first potlucks we ever came to when we
came out here
um this the this it was quite the
eye-opening mouth-shutting experience
yeah yeah it was like all these people
brought all these sides
and this one girl was like i i made this
this is paula deen's recipe and i'm like
eating it i'm like
really cause she's and then as i'm
eating it she's like and you know what
i used half the butter and half the
sugar that paula called for and it's
still good and i'm thinking
paula knows best bro she
have you seen the silhouette of that
woman she knows
how much butter and sugar you're
supposed to put in things right right
and there's just a different mentality
and you know what it's probably a better
mentality it's probably
a mentality that lives to that leads to
a longer
healthier life but when thanksgiving
only comes once a year
when you've decided to throw caution to
the wind
i could have unfurl the sails i could
have butter
injected directly into my veins on
thanksgiving i would do that
oh that was a thing we could make it a
tradition
and so i gotta so because dessert time
happened
and i was like oh there's a pumpkin pie
and then i they had labeled everything
and it was pumpkin pie vegan vegan
and i was like and there was like
chocolate pie
raw vegan what
and then it was like some kind of bites
vegan man and
now you know how vegan people normally
feel right
and here and so what i thought was i was
just like man i just want to go to
ralph's right now right now and just
get a pumpkin pie from ralph's you know
just get a grocery store pumpkin pie
put some whipped cream on top and then
unbutton my pants and enjoy myself
right you know so that was an adjustment
it was an adjustment that i feel like i
can be ready for next year mm-hmm
it just i think i'm gonna bring my own
butter and my own sugar
and i'm just gonna just squeeze squeeze
squeeze iv a squeegee of butter and then
left like a sugar shaker and i'm just
like
don't mind me you know just to kind of
get things out to the standard
uh just bring stuff and label it
unapologetically on vegan
yeah right that sounds like a good brand
yeah
and then the tagline is make it a
tradition
we sell it at walmart don't make
millions don't commercialize my
holidays i can't help but commercialize
things i i helped a lot of people man
but once i didn't make a dime one
traditional thing that happened was
is uh uh the host
said we're going to go around and we're
going to say what we're thankful for
we're going to do
because it's los angeles you kind of
have to say we're going to do the cliche
thing
and we're going to say what we're
thankful for
um and you know
everybody was saying kind of the
traditional things you know family
and friends what was your gut knee-jerk
reaction to to that announcement um
uh well i'm not i can think of three
what was my gut and usually reaction to
having the announcement of
of the assignment that this this cliche
thing was going to happen well there's
always a slight increase in heart rate
yeah i think that for every normal
normal person even somebody who don't
speak for people
i'm asking for you don't normalize your
response just tell me what yours was i'm
curious well a slight increase in heart
rate okay
uh and then uh normal most people that
would
and then like okay i got to say
something that sort of mixes humor and
heart
and heart in the right way this is a you
know this is a branding moment
um um i don't exactly remember what i
said i was thankful for
uh because because there was a second
question that i do remember everything
that i said
oh you don't you don't remember what you
were thinking no it was something about
new new friends and
family and then i said i i made a joke
um it went over well trust me
um but then the second thing that
happened while we were eating which i
found very interesting was there was a
guy there that was a life coach
again of course was he paid to be there
if you know you get if you get 25 people
together in los angeles
one of them will be a life coach so
that's code for something right i don't
know what if
you don't have one life coach per 25
people in los angeles the entire city
implodes
it's funny the the the cashier at sheetz
was a life
did he have a tag how did you know he
was a life coach
well a hat if someone is a life coach or
a vegan
or into crossfit you know it yeah right
you know what i'm saying you find out
pretty early in the conversation right
so i uh that's true
i um he sends a list of those things he
stands up and he says
um uh we're gonna all answer this
question and again i i liked it because
i it was intentional conversation
and there's 25 people at a table and
you're kind of talking to the people
around you but then
it's kind of putting everybody on the
spot even the kids the kids had my
both of my kids had to stand up and
answer this question but it was the
traditional question of
if you had a superpower what would it be
and what would be your first mission
oh i haven't i actually haven't heard
what would be your first first mission
was new to me because that's the kind of
thing that a life coach adds to it you
understand right
because what's your favorite superpower
that's just normal folk
what's your first mission life coach
business card
here you go but the heart rate goes up
even more when that happens yeah i'm
like
now curveball now now it's
precious time to shine
um so i said um and it was we
one guy requested he said can we instead
of going around can we just do popcorn
style can we just as you know
what you're going to share it's like
that's a good idea
why is that a good idea uh because
he wanted he wanted to get dibs because
of invisibility
inevitability of it coming to you and
you're just thinking about
what you're going to say like he had a
reason it was good i thought it was
great at the moment
but uh i had actually had this exact
discussion with my wife the week before
now we've talked about what our favorite
superpowers would be before we argued
about it at some point on a debatorama i
think
if you believe in freedom you believe in
flight
invisibility is to hide yourself from
freedom
like a shameful naked mole rat don't be
deceived flight is not heroic
it is self-absorbed showboating look at
me
i'm air swimming i can't remember
anything that we do around here but
i know we've talked about superpowers
and i personally
invisibility versus invincibility was
one of our first but we did invisibility
versus flight and then
yeah i've always said that the
teleportation is the is the superpower
that i would choose
because it replicates technically can
replicate
invisibility and flight for all
practical purposes
i i would are you asking me now because
i would choose
uh being able to double myself and be
invisible so i could creep on myself and
not even know it
well interesting and disturbing but
i did not say that because that's this
the canned answer
i actually said what thanksgiving you
don't eat canned ham
i was i jesse and i were were with each
other eating
something and i was eating some bad food
is this a dream
no no you lost this is the week before
they gave me the answer to the
superpower thing okay
and i said you know what if i could have
a superpower
it would just be to turn everything that
is bad for me
to eat into things that are good for me
the whole thing would just flip
so it would be like you know fried
chicken processed meats and it would be
not only would it taste good
but it would make me feel the way that
good healthy food would feel
and and be you know synthesized by your
body
so did you tell them this
and did that just incriminate you and
what you were con
the thoughts you were consumed by what
so i was like i'm going to go early
because i want so i can enjoy
everyone's answers oh i like that so
people got up and and said a couple of
things that were kind of fun kind of
interesting and i was like the third and
i said
well i've actually been thinking about
this because jesse and i were talking
about this
last week and i said that i would turn
everything that's bad for me into things
that were good for me
um and my first mission would be would
be to start eating
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best